hey guys and welcome back to the Leia
heilpan show joining me on the show
today we have a YouTuber he's a content
creator and he makes the best reaction
videos online with his mum and I think
he actually reacted to one of my videos
which is how I first discovered him so
let's welcome to the show sunny and the
Beast mum Elena welcome to the show
thank you so much for having us on Leah
I was just we were just talking about
this before but it's so funny how when
you do social media you start meeting
all these same exact people that you're
just watching online not long ago so
like I don't even think it was nine
months ago that we met online for the
first time and here we are I'm meeting
like sartorial sneako all these other
big guys so it's been it's been a crazy
year yeah it's been wild we got to get
you meeting a lot of these people though
right so far
yeah you do it yeah I've met snico I
think was the only other one that I've
met yeah just Nico yes once you start
meeting a few famous people
um it doesn't really get as cool anymore
but it's funny because you say famous
and I just don't think of these people
as famous I'm feel like we're in this
like online social media Echo chamber
and everyone's just like hustling and
trying to do their thing you know I know
it's just the circle now it's hilarious
it's crazy especially being based uh in
Miami I know you're visiting Miami so
how are you finding Miami because you do
see people just walking around who you
see online you know so how are you
finding it
um I like Miami a lot my dad was
stationed here for four years in the
Coast Guard just a few years ago so I'm
already familiar with the area and
whatnot but I was still young back then
like I'm only 19 years old now so now
I'm finally able to go out and actually
enjoy how Miami's supposed to be enjoyed
at 19 just about
oh no well 22 yeah when I go out on 20
22. yeah
okay but um yeah it's a good time
there's uh the girls are definitely very
different here like if you're gonna base
women just on Miami girls you're totally
mistaken like it's it's a very different
group of women compared to the rest of
the world that's that's true because I
think one thing which frustrates me with
this whole Space is everybody is based
out of Miami so when they talk about
women they talk about men and women
Dynamics yeah yeah it's a very it's very
um like uh narrow-minded it's very
focused on Miami girls so how how are
Miami women different to Boston you said
you're from well Boston they're super
liberal so that's the first thing like
here the women are a little bit more
open-minded to being conservative and
not totally brainwashed but um the women
here I mean they're a lot more
promiscuous
um they have like that stew I hate that
Miami accent like the girl Miami
actually what is that like not it's not
like period but do you know what I'm
talking about has he got like attitude
to it they have like attitude it's like
a mix of Spanish and English
I can't even I don't even know how to
explain it but it's just like it's it
just irritates me I don't know I like
the girl that is in the village in the
middle of Italy yeah it doesn't everyone
you're not gonna find that in my eyes
yeah you're not finding her here and in
Boston every all the girls are it seems
they're in sweatpants and Bruins
t-shirts oh yeah also like a bunch of
they're really fish here like a lot of
lilies yeah that's one thing though just
oh my
that I do like about Miami is the fact
that this everyone here
um
the standards are high like everybody's
trying to look fit everybody's trying to
look more beautiful more handsome more
sexy so you know you don't like no one's
walking around in sweatpants here you
know everyone's walking around in their
best putting their best foot forward I
guess absolutely if they're in
sweatpants they're designer sweatpants
yeah
and they're custom tailored but but that
is that far I mean I I pulled in here
this morning and I'm driving around it's
10 o'clock in the morning and I'm
looking and I'm like this you know I see
these young women in these outfits they
look cheap and overdone it's 10 a.m what
are you doing
you just you just look like you're
desperate for attention so maybe that's
just the old curmudgeon in me looking at
these young girls and hearing my
father's voice we would be driving
around I was born and raised in Brooklyn
and we'd drive through Brooklyn
Manhattan all the time we were always on
the road having a good time and he would
be like he would see a woman dressed
promiscuously and he would be like you
see that
that woman's dressed like a [__] and
then he would just keep driving like he
like he didn't say anything and it
taught me very young you know to be
careful about how you present yourself
so let's get it let's just get into that
then I'm curious then
times have obviously changed I feel
fathers aren't doing that anymore
they're not sort of giving their
daughters that type of guidance so from
from your perspective Elena why why is
it not like that anymore because that's
amazing that's that's a great father it
was a great father he was a wonderful
father well I'll tell you I think I
think off the top of my head it's
because of feelings okay so first of all
you don't want to hurt your kids
feelings everyone's like they have to be
able to express themselves and this
whole Express Yourself thing that
started in about the 80s was really cute
at first and it gave everybody a little
more room to be themselves and then it
is obviously we can see gone off the
rails completely now people are
expressing themselves to the point where
I don't even have to
um they're defying logic at this point
right and I'm supposed to buy it
um there's that there's the
demasculinization of men which I know
you've talked about before and I've
talked about with him that men aren't
allowed to speak their minds anymore
because the wives go Hush Hush leave her
alone let her Express herself you don't
want to give her a complex no matter
what you do your kids go into therapy
okay Nomad or or having to cope with
with life
so protecting your kid from every
feeling and every criticism is actually
going to set them up in a worse way to
be weaker
you've been good about that even with
germs making sure you go to therapy no
no not not that but like not Sheltering
me from stuff ever since I was little
even the parents now that are like
afraid of germs they're kid touching
dirt like I was licking the floors at
Costco really well yes I didn't
encourage that but he was about a year a
year and a half old when he was able to
walk and he went on this lick phase for
like six months and you licked
everything and we were in Costco and I
turned around and he was his little
toddler butt was in the air and his
hands on the floor and he was licking
the floor and I thought oh this kid's
gonna have a good immune system yeah but
I didn't over protect him I told him
terrible stories when he was little to
scare him like about kidnappers there's
one specifically that there was a man
named Igor that lived in the in the
sewers okay and there was one day me and
my friend yeah I'm terrified because if
I left my mom he'd come out of the
sewers and grab me and so there was one
day me and um me and my friends were
throwing like pennies down there and she
said he's gonna buy a bazooka and blow
us up wow oh yeah I just I like to make
up stories yeah to for the kids to scare
them a little bit and they all believed
in Igor but he was in the sewers and
they had to walk nearby us I wasn't
overly protective but I taught him there
was I kind of feel a little bad about
this actually I don't but he was about
seven and I was telling him about the
story of Adam Walsh who was a little boy
a very famous who was kidnapped and in
America and they found his body
decapitated and he had been sexually
abused and tortured and then decapitated
during this kidnapping his father is
John Walsh who's now
um runs that show America's Most Wanted
he devoted his whole life to finding
horrible people anyway he's about seven
I tell him this story just so that he
doesn't get in the car with a stranger
yeah he's not the kid that's tricked by
candy and puppies and he said to me
Mommy
can you please stop telling me because
I'm really scared now and I smiled and I
was like okay I did my job yeah you
should be terrified it's a terrifying
world out there but it was right
everyone else wants to protect their
children and back to the that girl looks
like a [__] comment
this this this keeping your child in a
bubble doesn't help them yeah at all it
helps them to not understand boundaries
and human behavior and to not be able to
take criticism is is a terrible thing
and that's why all these kids are
depressed in their in their rooms
yeah crying in a puddle all day all day
long instead of living life yeah I mean
even even my parents they taught us
terrible stories I remember one time me
and my brothers we were in Spain we were
so young
um Gideon's gonna listen and fully
remember this
um we were playing pool and there were
these guys that were getting a bit too
friendly with us they were like grown
men and they invited both my brothers
and me I think back to their house to
see their trophies
anyway I can't remember what happened
but I was uncomfortable I'm obviously
the youngest and I I'd run back to mum
and dad and then mum and dad came to get
us or whatever anyway in the car just
remember my mom and dad being so angry
that we even entertained it and they my
mom in detail told us what they would
have done to us and I was like and then
I remember my dad being like you're
being too graphic and then mom's like no
she needs to hear it they all need to
hear it and like to this this was over
this is like I don't know 20 years ago
do you remember that yeah we were in
Spain and yeah it's crazy he sticks with
you yeah yeah tough love it matters
that's happened to me before I was
grabbing like Chinese food and some guys
started talking to me he's like you know
my son he plays hockey at the park and
he just made up a name and he was trying
to get me to go in the car with him but
this one uh she trained me well yeah
yeah oh thank God so let's get into this
Dynamic so how how long firstly how long
have you been creating content together
and how did that start well the content
what's today the 19th it's a year and
two days since our first happy
anniversary great thank you since the
first ever video but I've been doing
content for about two and a half years
now but it's been with different little
brands of mine so I used to have like a
stocks and crypto brand
um where I would talk about Finance nfts
crypto all that kind of stuff I'm not
really too into that anymore to be
honest I kind of just focus on this
um I was also like a semi-professional
fortnite player which a lot of people
don't know it's hilarious when people
recognize me from from those days but um
yeah the mom stuff is new it's only a
year old I switched off of the crypto
the crypto brand and when when we're
really hard at this but how did it start
was it by accident was it just like oh
Mama I've made this video and then your
mom's like Oh like I've got something to
say and then it just no no so all right
I ran a company in the web 3 space it
was based around nfts and the nft market
basically [__] itself within like 48
Hours like volume went from here to
basically nothing and with nfts if
there's no volume the market basically
goes to zero because it's not like
crypto where it'll go down a little bit
maybe take a big dip if nobody's buying
your nfts they're literally worth
nothing so the market absolutely should
have shut itself so I had to find
something else to do because that
company was just falling apart and I
always knew I wanted to be a content
creator and a YouTuber so I I thought
like what's the way that I can go viral
in the quickest way possible because
what I typically do is I find things
that are extremely viral and I find
Pockets that are missing inside to place
myself into it to capitalize off of that
virality so I did this with the stocks
and crypto page like when I started that
I didn't know a single thing about
stocks I made a video that was like if
you bought into GameStop one year ago
what it would be worth today I actually
like started if you invested Trend which
is such a stupid Trend because it
doesn't teach you anything obviously but
um yeah I I I so like I start I know
it's so dumb but I started gaining a
really big following on that page
quickly and rather than pivoting it um
to something else I just decided to
become the stocks guy so I bought like
all of Robert kiyosaki's books
um different things about trading and
just learned as much as possible to keep
making good videos and then that's
actually what led me into the web 3
space but um where was I going with this
but how did you stop with Mom yeah yeah
exactly so like I analyzed that um the
same thing with the nfts I was able to
hop on that Trend so with any when um
Andrew Tate was the most viral thing in
the world I never saw anyone make a mom
reacts video and I know my mom's
hilarious I didn't know she'd be this
good on camera obviously because like
you never know how it's going to go when
you put the camera on but um yeah one
day I just sat down posted this is my
first ever YouTube video and within a
week it was at over a hundred thousand
views wow wow yeah so like I studied the
algorithm for a few weeks to make sure I
hit the nail on the head like if you
look at cuff do you know who cough boys
are the other mom reacts guys so if you
look at their titles my titles and their
titles are the exact same if you look at
my thumbnails it's Nico style if you
look at my description it's the same as
vid IQ because I what what I teach and
like this is like the biggest cheat code
to be honest is you just analyze what
other people do well and you do it
better everyone in business that does
well knows this you don't need to
reinvent the wheel and it goes the same
thing for content to hashtags to the
audios that you're using to the video
Trends so I just pluck everything else
that I see people doing well and I put
it in my own way so smart
for 19 after
Wards yeah but that was the this people
wouldn't believe me if they said how
calculated this whole strategy was like
before I ever posted my mom reacts video
I was sitting outside in the back with
my friends just drinking bees wow and I
was telling them like this is the plan
I'm gonna launch a program I'm gonna
hire a bunch of I'm gonna teach people
short-term marketing get them really
good at it they're going to start
pushing my content I'm gonna be chilling
with the milk boys soon nice nice
because I was still like in that stage
back then where that stuff is cool but
now I've met them and it's like it's
just whatever now it's that's the
funniest that's what I was saying about
Miami you know are they celebrities I
don't know they're just people that I
see they're celebrities everywhere
and that's the thing too once you how
would you say Fame has changed your life
because I don't consider myself like
famous yet like I will be but not yet
that's a personal question it's also
different for women of course it's very
different
um okay well how's it well um I've lost
a lot of friends I'd say because I
became very open about my opinions
during the whole flu thing that happened
I lost a lot of friends because I was
very vocal about how I didn't think it
was real
um you know I'm very anti-force
medicines and stuff like that so and
then I'm also very anti-feminism and I
hate all of that so I'm just very vocal
about that and I and I'm genuinely so
passionate about it that I can't really
have friendships with people that
disagree with me on that because I know
that sounds really like Echo
chamber-like and narrow-minded but it's
not it's because they will get offended
by just random things that come out my
mouth during the day you know like if I
see a man that like I I think is like
not attractive I'll be like he looks gay
do you know what I mean yeah and that's
like not politically correct and that
would offend like one of my old friends
you know or if or if I'm like um oh you
know I'm dating this guy and like I
really want to make him like this like
nice pie or whatever like a friend would
be like you don't have to do that you
know and I'm like and then and then we
just have issues you know or if I'm like
um oh I'd rather just do this for a man
and not have to like work like this
we're not going to get on me and a
girlfriend does that make sense so
absolutely yeah so it's changed like my
friendships but it's also allowed me to
meet more like-minded people
um and then it makes dating a little bit
uh you know interesting but that's
another story it is funny how people
that I literally grew up with they're
not like unfalling me and they don't
want to associate with me anymore and
like I feel like I don't say anything
that crazy the funny thing too is I was
calling out this [__] from the start too
during
um the flu during the flu during all
this I was calling black lives matter a
scam yeah and so I was known as like the
racist in high school well not but like
I think that must be so hard at such a
young age because you're in high school
so you're forced to be with these people
I was like see ya I'm moving countries
I'm going to Miami where people think
like me yeah well a lot of it was um was
online and the funny thing is like most
of the kids that I talk to from my high
school that rock with what I do now
they're all the black kids because it's
not even the black people that get mad
about this stuff it's the white saviors
it's the dumb they had everyone so
brainwashed during it you have no idea
what it was like to be in high school at
that time it was unbelievable you had to
wear they set up lines in the hallways
so you had to walk on the arrows and if
like you crossed over to the other side
of the hallway if your mask went below
your nose it was the I can't even
explain the amount of stupidity we had
to deal with and when I would ask my
physics teacher about it and what now
he's like well if you keep the mask
below your nose it it makes the chance
of like something flying out a little
bit more what do you want his grandma to
die he lives with his grandma and they
would
yeah it was unbelievable it was
unbelievable you know what was it two or
three weeks to flatten the curve and I
was like okay we're gonna we're gonna do
this because we didn't know we were all
still in the dark in the very beginning
I said we'll do this
and you know a week and a half in he's
like Mom I'm gonna jump off the roof I
gotta get out of here and I all right
let's just go go play with your friends
by two weeks I was calling my friends me
like y'all coming over oh yeah we I
can't take this anymore and we all just
threw in the towel and none of us got
deathly ill everyone's alive nothing bad
happened and we all just stopped stopped
caring so what what is that I mean I
know it's one a piece of anecdotal
evidence but everyone has the same
everyone has the same story yeah yeah
but that to me being in school and we'll
get to this must be so difficult right
now because you really do have to debate
with with I hate you I don't know if I
could say the r word [__] teachers
can I say can I say that sure they're
just such idiots like it just you know
what I mean
um and yeah I can only imagine having to
follow the arrows and even shopping was
it was just a nightmare in England we
had to like shop like clockwise because
you know if you go anti-clockwise covid
can catch you oh I forgot we did that
here too we had uh you could only go one
way on a supermarket aisle oh my God
they had big dividers at the lunch
tables you were splitting the fours
and if you talk to people around it you
had to put your mask on like we're gonna
hang out after school it was just
it it genuinely annoys me even talking
about this yeah yeah well let's get back
to the Dynamics between you two so I'm
curious okay so Elena how's it been
creating content with your son isn't
that probably something you never
imagined that you would do never in a
million years yeah so I had waited 16
years to get back into the live
entertainment industry because I left it
when he was born to you know since I
wanted to raise him and I always missed
it and wanted to get back so I got back
in in December of 2019 I said the word
sorry uh I got back in December of 2019
and then in March of 2020 the world shut
down live entertainment was the first
thing to go
and we were also the last to reopen so I
lost the job that I got started my own
agency and started promoting comedy
shows in places like Texas and Oklahoma
where there were no not as many
restrictions down in Florida so I was
able to you know continue to make a
living he had in the meantime made all
this money but I didn't you know I was
still the head of the household and I
wanted to run things
um and I was I was proud so I worked and
worked and worked and I just felt like I
was beating my head against the wall
because it kept getting extended the
light at the end of the tunnel kept
going out and in um
about the end of March early April of
2022 I at that point I had started going
to this church and starting to get
really into
um more into Christianity I was raised a
Catholic but I joined the Baptist so I
literally hit my knees and I prayed and
I said listen
like you take it because no matter what
I'm doing it's not working and I'm
exhausted and I I literally I don't know
if I ever even told you this I I gave it
to God and I said please
Take the Wheel kind of and
then in July you know nothing changed
immediately but it was about three
months later that in July he walks in
and he's like hey Ma you feel like doing
a video I'm going to start a YouTube
channel you want to do a video and I was
like
whatever fine I said can I can I he's
gonna Bang Yeah I was like
a mom reacts video I was like what does
that even mean I didn't even know what
it was yeah I use YouTube to listen to
like Bon Jovi songs right you know yeah
that was my whole thing I didn't really
listen to a lot of podcasts a little bit
here and there
um you know maybe some daily wire stuff
that was it
and
he he we're getting ready and I said can
I have a glass of wine because I'm
nervous
I was nervous I never liked taking
pictures of myself I don't like being in
front of the camera and it was a big
leap for me to sit down so I had a half
a glass of wine sat down
I had the bottle right there refilled it
and we did it used to drink like all the
first few months I drank every single
episode oh yeah some there's a couple
words where I was like I was drunk
there's a couple Clips out there where
she's uh yeah oh yeah and you can tell
you can tell right away
yeah and uh and I kind of felt like you
know the way I look at it is this is
something I never would have imagined
for myself
and I feel like
I could not be happier it's perfect it's
perfect I love it I love working with
him the first you know six months things
were really smooth between us when we
moved to Florida I think the big move
from Boston to Florida was just really
stressful and I I talked to a lot of
people and quite honestly I mean we we
had trouble getting along for a couple
months and it just felt like we I it
broke my heart because we always had
such a sweet relationship yeah because
we started an agency and started like
because she quit that other thing to
start working on this full-time and
working with my mom on like the agency
as well as filming and spending time and
like being in a new spot without all my
friends it's just like it's too much Mom
time yeah and so it just you know
obviously that causes I didn't have my
friends either it was hard it was too
much togetherness and he's 19. who wants
to spend that much time with their
mother yeah so we really and but I feel
like we're past that now I know we are
and it feels so much better yeah
definitely yeah it was it was we've had
some Growing Pains yeah Sonny I'm
curious some of the stuff that that you
know this red pill content talks about
is like dating and girls and like you
know it can be quite explicit at times
do you ever feel uncomfortable talking
about that in front of your mum honestly
not at this point like even in the First
videos I've like sworn in front of my
mom and I guess that's not a good thing
to do but I don't know like growing up
with um I mean my dad's in my life of
course but like in the house with my mom
most of the time we talk about a lot of
stuff not really like my girl's life
like explicitly like I'll talk to her
about if I'm talking to a girl right but
we'll talk about the conversation with
the girl but no we certainly don't talk
about look at our closed doors jugs like
I would never yeah yeah you wouldn't no
but I will say he'll show me a picture
of a girl and I'm like she looks cheap
yeah it's cheap and you know what it is
parents have a sense with people and
this is why I've started changing my
mind on like arranged marriages and
stuff like that because I used to think
it was the craziest thing in the world
but every single business partner every
single friend that I've had that my mom
was skeptical of and didn't like ended
up snaking me in some way and they're
not in my life anymore so the the mom
[__] test you need to take that into
consideration it's very important with
friendships with business they have that
and I don't know what it is if it's a
spiritual thing where you know to
protect woman's intuition maybe and
that's what they're trying to kill in
women which pisses me off so much what
do you mean like they're trying to kill
that feminine motherly sense that all of
you guys have because
it's not as much of a I'm trying to
think of the best way to explain this
like a physical thing like men have
where you go out and you do the work
like you guys really are spiritual
spiritually amazing beings like how that
I don't know how she does that like it's
a hun it's every single time and I I
didn't see any red flags in the people
oh I'm thinking there's a few going
across my mind right now that I'm like
oh thank God he listened on that one or
or I wish he had listened sooner on that
one but you do trust me now and you've
told me that and I appreciate it not
that I'm always right but actually and
then the dad like my dad doesn't even
remember any of my friends names so it's
totally different yeah I mean it's
interesting because actually Myron made
this point and I've never had anyone
make it before and it really just I was
like okay that's correct it's basically
like people um the term Mommy's boy is
like a derogatory term used to purposely
separate a man from his mother so that
the man then is more vulnerable to all
these like vicious attacks because the
mother knows right so if you have a if
you have a good mum in your life she can
warn you about that's a bad woman that's
a bad woman right so if we keep saying
um mommy's boy then you're going to want
to like separate from your mom and
you're not going to want to take her
advice so Myron actually brought that to
light and I think that's so true yeah
that's why I love talking and listening
to those guys because they always expand
on your points in such interesting ways
like Andrew Tate always makes like the
craziest analogies that I never would
have thought of but it really does
change your mind with a lot of that
stuff so speaking of Tate I'm really
curious what your opinion is
um obviously that's the content which
made you go viral at first I think you
reacted to a video which I did about
Andrew so what's your overall take on
everything that's going on at the moment
I just think he's like really
misunderstood you know
um obviously he's done some stuff in the
past that like I think only fans is
degenerate and all that kind of stuff
but I'm not I don't I don't know I don't
hate him for that like everyone everyone
goes through stuff Malcolm X used to be
um a pimp on the street you used to pimp
out girls and then look look what he
look at the impact that he had but yeah
I think that he's really just
misunderstood a lot of the people that
dislike him they don't have good reasons
why they just listen to the mainstream
media and they see the news titles and I
don't I don't mess with that at all like
I think people need to start critically
thinking more I even did an interview I
don't know whatever I'll talk about it I
even did an interview video in in South
Beach where I asked mainly black people
can black people be racist right and so
obviously all of them were like they
were [__] on white people for a lot
of it and then I asked them have you
ever had a racist experience with white
people in person and all of them said no
but I could name a hundred times that
they've been racist to me and white
people have been attacked but I'm not
allowed to talk about that so in real
time I was able to show them that that
was programming in their head because
you don't have any real life experience
to back up these thoughts and I think
it's the same thing with Andrew Tate and
a lot of these other guys people are
very easily programming nowadays and
it's scary because the next
flu that they Pawn us since we're in the
community we we are kind of biased
because we're going to think like oh
most people don't think like that we're
waking up but trust me a lot of people
are still sleeping so the next thing
they pull it's going to come hard and
quick very asleep they're very asleep
it's so frustrating so I'm working on
you know a particular project right now
and I feel this anxiety like I have to
get it out I have to get it out you know
and then I I then I go out and talk to
people in the real world and I'm like
I've got plenty of time these people are
dead asleep and it's really disturbing
how how far people have their head in
the sand and I'm just talking about
Average Joe's I'm talking about the
below Average Joe's they are really they
really need a big wake-up call
and they need to be told some facts and
then the people who are half awake still
so many of them don't even want to look
at facts yeah I think it's too difficult
especially when you reach a certain age
and you have your entire life based off
you know this traditional idea of how
the world works and then it becomes too
painful to wake yourself up or your your
illusion of reality just shatters you
know it's like it's difficult to pull
people out the Matrix they'd rather just
stay in The Matrix because it's easier
you know it's easier like sometimes I
sorry to say like sometimes I even wish
that I wasn't like awake sometimes
sometimes I wish I was asleep because I
felt like my life would be easier until
until one day it's not right until they
force you to take something yeah until
it hits you right till it hits home
because it does head home to everybody
eventually and one of these horrible you
know political social cultural like
atrocities that are going on around us
it's going to hit everybody at home yeah
and but why how bad does it have to get
talk to people and you know people who
are kind of awake and they're like yeah
I can't say anything though you know my
wife tells me it's not worth the trouble
or I don't want to lose my job or you
know I I'm three years from retirement I
gotta I gotta I gotta lay oh yeah you've
done the street interviews how often are
people like oh my job I can't I can't
talk you're on a street interview I know
are you that
I know do you know what really annoyed
me it was like so during the flu I was
so vocal and I got really frustrated
when other people just were too afraid
to say anything and I'm like do you not
understand like this is like life or
death right now like this is freedom or
no Freedom you have to say something you
have to speak up people are too afraid
and I just I I maybe I'm too harsh but I
just have I find it very hard to respect
people who just went along with it for
an easy life
um yeah maybe I'm too harsh but no I
totally agree with you yeah if people
it's the same thing if people like
actually don't like Andrew T I won't
even do business with them yeah it's
getting to that point because I'm like
you're so easily programmed and back to
the Andrew tape point A lot of people
are like it's like he's trying to be
Andrew like I I get that a lot and it's
like yeah why wouldn't you want to try
to be like that yeah like become
extremely successful take care of
everybody that you love in your life to
like a degree you couldn't even you
wouldn't imagine possible with a normal
job you're strong he's still fighting
every day like who wouldn't want that a
ton of women respect him like I don't
know that seems like the the dream life
to me I don't know why why I'm the bad
guy for working towards that Elena
what's your take on Andrew
all right so one of the First videos
that we watched about him
I learned you know I learned all the
accusations against him and you know
none of that really bothered me because
right off the bat I was like is this
true where's the proof I started asking
questions I'm still mad that he didn't
go to his father's funeral I'm never
gonna let that go and I'll tell him
straight to his face that's the one
thing that hurts me he said because he
had just started you know his webcam
businesses in Romania and he had all
these girls living in the house that
were um
you know he had to take care of and he
couldn't take off the few days to fly
from Romania to the states to go to his
father's funeral or he didn't have the
money or whatever it was
she goes to every funeral in the country
I'm old-fashioned it's ridiculous like
that's not ridiculous I'm sorry that's
not I'm not trying to be rude yeah it is
a big part of life yeah death is one of
the biggest things that's going to
happen to all of us and I do believe in
Tradition and custom and showing up to
support the people
to support the people that you know
loved the dead person and also to grieve
properly myself and then I wrap it up
and I move on like I'm I'm good at grief
for that reason because I have been
through it a lot of times and I it
bothers me though his own father he
prioritized anything over that and he
will justify it to death that said
and I would say that to his face and I
would love to talk to him and try to
explain to him the importance of
funerals for the future so he doesn't
make that mistake again
but that said
the guy is disciplined he's successful
he's a businessman he speaks his mind I
mean these are these are qualities that
I really like in a person in a friend in
uh somebody that my son is looking up to
I think you know I I don't like all his
takes on you can have you know children
with multiple women and that's okay I
think that that is a piece of him that
is undisciplined
but generally speaking you know I'm not
going to look at one little or two
little things that I think the guy said
or did wrong and and use that to make an
entire character case out of him there's
far more good isn't that positive for
the world I think you know a lot of
people mistake his family unit like I
don't even know if you watched the last
podcast with Tucker or any of those guys
yeah I will but people mistake it as
like he just has a bunch of
um a bunch of women that he doesn't
really love and he just hooks up with
them and then there's kid little Tates
running around everywhere like his
family reminds me of a lot how ours like
should have been in a way where it's
like you and your sisters or like me and
my um my dad's brothers and I'm around
all my cousins all the time like he
likes having the whole actual family
there together it's like I would have
grown up around my cousins my uncles
everyone under the same house or within
a couple houses of each other sort of
how like you grew up in Brooklyn right
so that's kind of the way his family
works like all under one big house
compared to
I don't think he lives with the women
though I could be wrong I have no idea
I'm pretty sure that I don't know I
don't know he doesn't talk about it if
you think about that what do you think
about the having multiple children with
multiple women on purpose
so I think
um I think reality matters like if you
if you're a high status man and you can
command that then like okay and if all
the women agree and everyone's happy and
everyone can sense then fine like you do
what you want but I still think raising
children should be between just one man
and one woman I think that's the
healthiest way to do it I think the
nuclear family is the healthiest way
um you know I I feel my parents um have
always been very happily married and
they they raised us and I think the
reason why me and my brother are so like
normal I think we're extremely normal
other people may not think so but I
think we're very grounded and normal and
like we don't have any like issues we
don't have any like chips on our
shoulder like me and Gideon were good
right we're healthy people and I think
that's because mum and dad raised us in
a healthy environment mom made dinner
dad was home at 7 30. dinner was on the
table I remember when we were younger
mom would say if we did something
naughty she'd be like just wait till
your father gets home then I see Dad
come home and you'd see the whites of
his eyes you know and I think that that
Dynamic is extremely healthy like mum
never wondered where Dad was
um you know Dad was always showing mum
so much love and I really think that's
why me and Gideon are just so normal
again I think we're normal we don't have
any issues um and then we go into the
real world
um you know you know once you like leave
the nest or whatever and you see how
messed up people are and it's because
divorce is so high it's because men are
having children with multiple women
um women have having children with
multiple different men and it's all a
mess and so I really think the nuclear
family is the best thing but like you do
you and you know it's not for me to pass
judgment and if if the women are happy
to share you and and because you're just
so amazing they they want to have kids
with you no matter the fact that you
have kids with other women then so be it
I don't care it's probably not something
that I could do but you know as long as
he's taking care of all of them
um not just financially but emotionally
and physically and all of that then then
that's good but I think it can be very
difficult to do you know I I think I
think one woman's difficult enough right
like we're so demanding we want like my
brother always says to me that um women
are very draining and it's true we want
you know we want your time your money
your love your affection everything we
want everything from you you know and
then how are you going to give that to
multiple women I think that's difficult
but it's like a nightmare actually it
sounds like a right nightmare I think
all these people all these women
messaging you where are you when are you
coming home they're like it's enough one
woman like you know and then the women
are dealing with each other oh I I I
couldn't I I couldn't do I could I
couldn't deal it would make me go crazy
and then I'd become like and I'd become
like an unappealing person and I
wouldn't be a desirable person anymore I
think I'd become like crazy and you know
they always say like men are always like
oh my ex is crazy it's like you probably
made her a little crazy didn't you yeah
like because you had you didn't you know
you were doing all these things that
made her question you let that match
yeah
um I think I think also another problem
with it is the children themselves so
now you have different children living
in different households with different
women you can't raise your children Cons
with any sort of consistency the way
Leah and Leia and uh Gideon were raised
two parents same house same rules all
the time you can't control multiple
women and how they're gonna react and
treat their children one may be warmer
one may be colder one may be loose one
may be a disciplinarian and so your kids
are just gonna be this you know
mishmash of
values right and I think the nuclear
family as well it creates so much
stability and that's one thing which I
remember growing up is like I always
knew that Mum and Dad would be there
even even up until I was I mean I was 25
I was back home and um it's like a year
ago I was back home in England and
something really a night we went out to
this horse racing thing and something
really dangerous and weird and bad had
happened
um to to someone and we drove home and I
called my mum and dad and I was like you
won't believe what happened we're coming
home blah blah blah and they and I just
felt so much comfort knowing that Mum
and Dad were there and that's at the age
of 25 and I was like mum and dad are
there thank God like they're there I'm
coming home they're both there and we
can like talk about it and they say
don't worry Leia you did the right thing
you're I'm sure I did the right thing
yes you did the right thing you know and
that just like fills you with so much
like comfort and stability and even now
that I can call my dad I can call my dad
and he'll answer the phone and and he'll
talk to me for like an hour about any
problem that I have and my mom like you
need that that is so important so
yeah my point was that it was he's just
misunderstood
you said in 10 minutes
yeah I mean I I totally get where you
come from and look here here's the thing
like I'm thrown into the red pill space
so like I try not to like I talk about
the women's stuff for like what I have
with my experience but everything comes
with life experience so my views in five
years are going to be completely
different or at least somewhat change
from where they are now so I mean I'm
always open to hearing New Perspectives
and and taking stuff into consideration
that like you know I've only had so much
experience with women I haven't had like
an extremely long-term girlfriend or
anything yeah so it's true you know um
but yeah I think like if I had brothers
or anything like us being in the same
area growing up um raising all of our
kids together I do think that's a cool
thing because I know that I was always
the happiest whenever I was with all my
cousins and whatnot we're all young
together playing hide and seek I think
growing up like that is a beautiful
thing and that's how a lot of it was in
Brooklyn as a kid right then you have
all your cousins and everyone right
there all the uncles and it's also like
and then we're at each other's houses
almost every day I have uncles and aunts
that'll call me out for stuff that you
guys might not call me out for but that
still helps build me as a person so I
don't know I think it's like extra
disciplinary forces coming in I agree
with that I think it's I'm like I always
wished we had like more cousins and more
aunt and uncles around like it was we
have a few but not that many so I
totally understand but I still think you
do need that nuclear family yeah so even
if it's my dad there yeah yeah even if
it's multiple nuclear families like
right on the same block I think that's
the coolest way to go about it because
it still does build that that Clan
aspect no I understand that and that is
part of all of this
of the masculinity and
see that's something which Tate has has
massively put in the spotlight um it's
something which we're all experiencing
you're only 19 but I'm curious what was
it like in school so how did the
teachers talk to you um so I know we
spoke about the flu but what were the
teachers saying about you know how to be
a man how to be a boy or whatever was
there ever like don't be too aggressive
don't be too competitive what was it
like in school oh wow I didn't I wasn't
even going to talk about that I was
always very competitive from a young age
you could probably speak onto this some
to some more than I don't even remember
but teachers used to ridicule me for
that wow right do you remember in like
fourth grade when I was competitive in
the the lady would get like mad and
she'd be calling you and stuff I mean I
was also because I was screwing around
she was the one she was the one teacher
that didn't like you though well the one
teacher up until 8th grader but I always
thought it was a bad thing that I was
competitive like I thought it was one of
my negative traits like even at recess
and stuff like I took that seriously
like this is the the mini hockey
Olympics right now like you think I'm
gonna be playing around yeah that's
crazy but right no you were competitive
you know what's interesting about that
is I never thought so this woman didn't
like Sunny he was always the class clown
I was in the principal's office my whole
life and then as a mother I was always
in the principal's office with him but
it was always over goofy stuff like uh
you know he made the whole class laugh
and the teacher's getting frustrated or
he played a practical joke it was never
he got in a fight or anything like that
so this particular teacher though could
not take it she was a first year teacher
she had been a lawyer and she decided
she she couldn't she didn't want to be a
lawyer anymore she wanted to work with
children and she wasn't really good with
children she wanted them to be these
little Zen creatures her whole uh
classroom was set up for mindfulness and
like you're like nine and ten-year-olds
they're coming in after a bowl of Lucky
Charms they're going to be off the walls
like that's just how it's going and she
wasn't prepared and she wasn't prepared
for him but I never until this very
moment realized that she also was
woke before we called it woke and
because it was we're talking 10 years
ago now
and she was probably one of those you
know Tamp down on the masculinity types
that I didn't really think of at the
time because it wasn't part of the
national conversation the cultural
conversation at the time we didn't
realize that they were trying so hard to
demasculinize men or I didn't well they
also just don't acknowledge any social
differences between men and women maybe
maybe they'll acknowledge that we're
different physically maybe but
emotionally speaking and how you guys
are different beings they don't they
don't acknowledge it at all so think
about it like if they're giving everyone
the same advice and most of it's very
feminine it just makes you weaker like
if you listen to the matrix's advice on
women
you would be able you would think it's
okay to cry in front of them you
wouldn't think that being a strong
masculine figure is important you
wouldn't be dominant in any way these
are all things that women love because
women are also naturally submissive yeah
this is brand new by the way this is
yeah a thousand years or plus of
recorded history this is new so for you
this is your whole life you don't know
any different I'm still old enough to
remember when men were allowed to be men
and women were from Mars and men were
from Venus there was a book that came
out I don't know let's say the 80s
everything in my mind is it's also
extremely hypocritical because they
teach all these women this garbage stuff
but now if you teach a man how to be a
man and do something to get what you
want from women now you're now you're
manipulating which I don't really
understand like if anyone was an
entertained shoes but a woman you think
that there would be news articles saying
woman manipulates men into doing only
fans work that would never be a thing
cardi B is openly admitted to drugging
this is a I know at this point has been
beat down a lot but this girl's getting
McDonald's sponsorships and she's
literally drugged in
or not drugged and robbed them drugged
and robbed I'm sorry yeah yeah both just
as bad yeah it's unbelievable
um that's interesting so you so you're
old enough to remember that it didn't
always used to be like this yes women we
were it was good to be feminine it was
good to be a woman I am though also
probably one of the first Generations
where I was raised
in a mixed I was a split so I would my
mother didn't let me play sports I think
some of my sisters played softball but I
I was like I wanted to play baseball and
it was like no take another ballet class
so she was a little bit more
old-fashioned and then there were the
the newer fangled women who you know
pushed their girls into sports so
probably maybe a quarter of my high
school class the girls played Sports
um
so we had this mix of these mixed
messages right you know of this is the
older generation of women above us they
were mostly Homemakers and mothers and
matriarchs of their families and and
that was nice it was fine and then we're
getting all these messages you can be
whatever you want being a doctor a
lawyer an airplane pilot anything is
okay for a girl just because a boy does
you know girls can be just as good as
boys and so I now look back and I think
that those messages were really
confusing and they were overbearing to a
point where you know we stopped talking
no one ever said to me you know do you
want to have kids when you grow up do
you see yourself getting married and
being you know a homemaker and taking
care of children or do you see yourself
you know it was all more like you can be
a businesswoman you can be this you can
be that anything but a mother and I know
other women had other experiences maybe
they heard more split message
but I think we were poisoned by it in a
way and I look now a couple Generations
later and these women are prioritizing
career to the point where they just
automatically have an abortion if they
get pregnant yeah because my career
isn't that insane and I you know women
of my generation I by the grace of God
never was put in that position and never
had to make that choice
but I did participate in that process a
couple of times by helping friends and
taking them and it was extremely
difficult decisions it was the culture
around that has changed and the culture
around women's psyches what they've done
to these young women and their
depression rates are higher than ever
before so it's not working it's not all
this feminist [__] is not making
women happier or stronger
I'll go back to your point earlier so
you're saying how ignorance is bliss in
a way sometimes you wish you didn't
understand all this and sometimes I'll
feel the same way because when you
really go down the rabbit hole and
realize how deep um how dark a lot of
this stuff that happened is it's like
damn I wish I didn't know this but then
also imagine if you listen to The Matrix
without their stuff you'd be on birth
control you'd be quadruple jabbed what
are they what are all the other things
there's a there's a million of them you
would probably be on Focus pills since
you were a little a little kid
antidepressants because you're fat they
wouldn't tell you that being fat is the
issue your diet would stink I mean I
could go on for for 10 hours about all
the about where your life would be no no
it's true and yeah I don't do any of
that just
in my old high school there was a trans
teacher
um mix I'm not going to say the last
name and one time they took the American
flag off of the wall oh my God and they
put a rainbow flag up they put the
American she she disgusting she whatever
um
what a [__] call her out yeah I
remember that she threw the American
flag on the floor and put up a rainbow
flag a year after I went to Boston Latin
School so this is the oldest public
school in the United States yeah a few
of the founding fathers went there so
it's a naturally very prestigious school
but they've ruined it because there also
used to be a test to get in and then now
they made it by neighborhood and guess
which neighborhoods they give all the
spots to of course yeah and then you
know now there's like the fights have
gone up by 100 X for the for the younger
classes and um
yeah a year after the the George Floyd
stuff happened on Zoom with 2 000 people
in it they're doing moments of silences
for George Floyd it's so weird it's all
really bizarre and I wanted to get back
to what you're saying about the the
feminism thing
um because to be honest I do think when
you're a young kid I do think it's nice
to let children be free to like explore
different things you know like I I did
ballet and I also did football
um and I would say I was a real tomboy
growing up because I have two brothers
and
um I was obsessed with wrestling you
know I actually used to physically
wrestle with my brothers Gideon was
always really nice he never like like
threw me down too hard but like yeah
we'd wrestle a lot you know I'd always
and I'd refuse to wear the color pink
and I was very free to to choose that
and I think that's important but but I
think that at the end of the day as soon
as I turned like 21 I just went straight
into my feminine like it just something
just happened I don't know and you just
go you just become a woman you know and
it's the same with it's the same with
young boys like okay if he wants to try
dancing or singing or something
traditionally girly or whatever let them
do it you know like I never played with
Barbies I played with action because of
my brothers right and so but eventually
nature does take over and and that
should people should be free then to you
know fall in line with that and not
think that it's bad but what you were
saying as well it is really true I think
it's really sad that they don't tell
young girls that you're going to want to
be a mother one day you know and that's
really sad because even in your even in
your early 20s like at 21 you don't
really it doesn't really hit you that
you're going to want to be a mum it's
more like your mid-20s it's something
just changes and they don't tell you
that and nobody talks to you about that
I think it's Jordan Peterson that
actually brought that up there's so much
focus on the woman's career you know you
can do this you can do that but we're
just not honest in society and it's the
same with men in the war of masculinity
they're not honest with young boys when
they say you know yeah you should be a
man you should you know you should be
tough you shouldn't cry in front of a
woman I'm sorry that's just how the
world is because your woman's not going
to respect you if you cry like that's
how the world is and they're just not
honest
um which which I think is really sad and
to further your point not only are they
being dishonest but they're making these
kids depressed and angry so they're
telling young girls women have been held
down from the beginning of time you're
going to go in the workforce and you're
going to be held back by men and there's
going to be men doing the same job who's
going to get paid more so now they're
angry and they feel like they are
they're being told that they have
something to prove
and so they're not even going at life
from a happy place they're depressed and
angry and they're telling men you're the
reason that women are unhappy you're the
reason that black people are you know
aren't at the top of the food chain or
more of them aren't because plenty of
them are yeah of course but we don't you
know we don't talk about that and talk
about that either yeah
um so they're telling you know these men
and these young women that that life is
miserable
victimization yeah I mean imagine you
know how I was raised generally speaking
I can see I've just talked about some
things that I think left me really mixed
up but generally speaking there was
positivity yeah in how we treated other
people be nice be nice to people you
know we're all different that's it don't
be an [__] that was the rule be your
life is full of possibility anything is
possible you can be whatever you want at
least they were positive messages nobody
was sitting telling me that you know I
was holding a other people down or other
people were holding me down it's just
nothing but anger and victimization now
and it's so sad it shows in the numbers
of depression and anxiety and suicide
rates it's true and I think that Society
has gone so far you know men are now all
feminine and women are all masculine
that I have a funny story I went
shopping with my brother because I was
trying to find a dress or whatever and I
I really value what what he says I'm not
buying a pair of shoes or a dress unless
Gideon says yes
um anyway we went shopping and he's like
there like stabbed you up straight you
know by my side and uh the the women in
the shop kept coming over to me I was in
French Connection in Aventura and the
women in the shop kept coming up to me
and they were asking me like are you
okay do you do you need any help because
they were worried that like I had like a
pimp next to me or something or like
some toxic man next to me being like
evil and demanding and telling me what
to wear and what to do and I'm like yeah
I'm fine and they just kept circulating
to see if like I was safe and it's like
no that's my brother he's a manly man
and want his opinion on what I'm wearing
so I'm gonna so yes he's standing
outside the dressing room not to control
me but to direct me and make sure that I
pick a nice dress
yeah wow so that's just they just make
an automatic assumption that that's a
bad guy yeah because they because like
men don't exist anymore
they just don't see normal they don't
see masculine men anymore so when they
see one they think like I'm in danger
was your dad really protective like that
I don't think I've seen more of a
protective brother than Gideon there's
actually one he's not protective can I
just clarify it's not a bad thing no but
it's not that he's protective right he
just he he he's just making sure that I
I'm on the correct path right like it's
not like he's like you can't go on any
dates you must stay home no he's just
like let me get you a good guy yeah why
don't you like it's not don't wear
makeup it's like wear makeup correctly
it's not don't look sex it's not don't
look sexy it's just don't look like
um a three or four yeah in the nicest
way don't cheat well the thing is
there's a lot of brothers that aren't
like that anymore that's why I say that
um I don't know yeah my father was
protective
I mean I just one funny story my sister
Lorraine was going on a date she was
about 17 and she was you know that we're
all sitting in the living room and uh
outside we hear a horn
honking
and Lorraine gets up and looks out the
window and she's like he's here and she
goes to walk out the front door and my
father jumped off of that couch
so fast and he was like oh you're not
going anywhere and he went outside and
ripped this poor guy a new one screamed
at him on the street in Brooklyn you
don't honk your horn from my daughter
what you know what the hell do you think
this is and scared him away and he
laughed and my sister ended up crying
and I was about you know she was 17 I
don't know I was
about nine or ten whatever and I I
remember just this like big scene in the
house and her screaming and crying and
running up to her room but that's how he
was like you're gonna treat my daughter
right yeah period and she ended up going
out with him again on a different date
he rang the bell he talked to my father
may I take your daughter out he did it
all right they dated for a couple years
he was the nicest guy on him and my
father
formed this really close Bond but my
father set the tone yeah and I think
that that's lovely I don't know like I
look back and I'm like that's just the
greatest thing that my father you know
yeah that he taught us that that's how
we were supposed to be treated even if
you know as an adult we ended up making
choices that were contrary to that
because we were stupid it's definitely
nice that you've been been very strict
with me about that stuff with women and
how to treat them how to open the doors
how to be a gentleman all that kind of
stuff it's gone a long way in my life of
course I know you get really annoyed
when I remind you that when you slip
like what what things do you have to do
to be a gentleman
what are some of the most important
things that you've taught me like we
know you can't ask you like if she's
taught you you should know thank you I'm
Sunny you
just that effect that's why I almost
sometimes feel bad doing the interviews
because you can ask someone a simple
question like what they say and on the
spot it's hard to list all of them yeah
you know what I mean I'm sorry no yeah
all right I'll change the subjects he'll
live he'll make it through I'll change
subject that's fine okay so I want to
talk about red pill content because I
feel that it has potentially gone too
far so I want to get your take do you
feel we're just in this post-red pill
era where everybody is just saying you
know the most insane things just to get
as much attention as possible you know
people are like saying like w Hitler and
stuff like that he's a bit ridiculous
you know what I mean so I'm just curious
do you think you can go too far with
this content yeah I definitely think you
can go down the red pill too far
especially a lot of the people that
consume most of it they don't even live
by it you know they sit in their
basement and they just comment this kind
of garbage all day and um I know a lot
of the red pill creators right now are
kind of annoying me because a lot of
people fake drama and they'll fake beef
just to try to grab and leech as much
attention as possible and because like
I've I've been hanging out with stiko a
lot and he's obviously a lot more famous
than I am and he can see how people are
always trying to leech off of his name
with this fake beef and all this
nonsense and um yeah I definitely don't
want to be a part of that kind of drama
like I don't like it is anything you
like you don't want to talk about in
that red pill space
um well there's like the vasectomies
thing which I think was really stupid
but that was also kind of taken out of
context like I don't know how emotional
mail that one yeah but like people
didn't even understand exactly what he
was talking about like he made a tweet
where he said if you were to do these
things this is like the way to become a
high value man the quickest and it's
like if you say how to make a million
dollars the quickest way and you say to
rob a bank it doesn't mean that's you're
not you're not advocating to do that you
know what I mean but you're saying if
you get a vasectomy you don't worry
about women then you would be able to
make it to the top quicker and people
just like I think misunderstood that and
then now everyone's saying the red pill
means to get vasectomies and like well I
mean there's a lot of like you know Mac
towel men going their own way it's just
like a massive like in-cell Community I
don't know I just no you know you
haven't heard of him I honestly like I
don't follow a lot of the ins like that
kind of stuff too much like I kind of
just try to live my life and yeah learn
from personal experience because like
even if one thing I've noticed when you
talk to a lot you're not I'm not saying
about you when you talk to a lot of
older people like my uncle my older
uncles and grandparents and whatnot
they're so smart because everything that
they're saying is based off of their
life experience so what they've seen
from their own eyes there's no
programming inside of them that's why I
value their words so much and when I
show them someone and their thoughts
because they know they know better than
I do and I can at least acknowledge that
that's the best thing you've said that
you know you can
learn from other people's knowledge and
wisdom that's the that's the shortcut in
life is talking to older people and
learning from their mistakes and not
insisting on
stumbling your way through life and
doing it my way and you can take
people's word with a grain of salt like
if I hear an older person tell me like I
should go back to college I'm obviously
gonna be like well you grew up in a
different time where College was
actually worth it like I'm not going to
listen to that but um I don't know my
uncle talking to him about men and women
Dynamics it's just it's the funniest
stuff in the world because he's the only
one that's with me on all of this stuff
talking about how like promiscuous women
like you don't want one of those he's
like you got to get the Virgin I'm like
he's still saying this stuff to me
then okay
I do because he'll say things that he he
will then take that and be like yes I
want to marry a virgin or a pure girl a
more pure girl and whatever and he goes
there aren't any they're not here I say
I say yeah they're there they're though
they're at church they're home you know
you have to change where you look you
need to become a religious man if you if
you want if you want to demand if you
want to be able to command yeah like a
woman that's Christian and she hasn't
been with anyone then you're going to
have to become a man worthy of that
which is a man that's like into God
Jesus and all of that yeah and I I
totally understand that and it's a
beautiful thing to know that because now
you know what you have to work with you
don't want to but you don't want to be
in charge all day and every day and you
don't have to be though but then you're
probably not gonna get
that in my opinion because like most
people most people but look it's it's a
religious thing to have those values you
know yeah yeah but it's not just about
being a virgin it's honestly like so
many of these women have like 20 plus
bodies and you can see like I I've said
this I don't think I've said this to you
but you can look in a woman's eyes oh
God and see how many bodies she has and
I am scary good at this every time
almost most of the time I've said it to
these girls I guess it but you can like
this sounds insane but you're terrifying
oh no you can as a woman what is it is
it the fake eyelashes like what is it
you can look into their soul tell me how
so like the best way that I explain this
is like it has to do with pheromones so
obviously women women give up give up
sex like a man makes you crack like
you're the lock in a way you know you
allow people yeah and so like when
you're out at the club and there's these
girls talking to you you can tell when
they're trying to get something out of
you or when they're trying to sleep with
you because they're I feel like it gives
off different pheromones but that's in a
club setting what about just like if you
meet a girl and but even just off of
like their mannerisms the way they talk
like you
it's maybe it's just a superpower maybe
I'm just a maybe I'm just a superhuman
but I don't know like I feel like I can
okay and you can tell like it also has
to do with innocence like a lot of the
time these girls are virgins like
they're they're more at home they're
very innocent you can tell like this
girl hasn't had her heart broken 20
times you can just look at them would
you agree with that to some extent or
you think I'm totally insane I don't
think you're totally insane I I'm still
processing it but I do think you can
tell I I think it would be easier to
spot innocence yes than to determine not
innocence yes right yeah I think it's
interesting because men keep going on
about they want a pure girl who hasn't
had her heart broken 20 times right so
then like why do men take responsibility
and stop breaking these women no this is
another thing that I talk about being
mean to these sweet women I'm totally
against that I think that if you go out
with a virgin
people let's say like I'm if I were to
go out with a virgin or something like
and like this is like the most innocent
like this is a peak Purity in a female
is a virgin to an extent so if I go out
with her and she's down to sleep with me
we've gone on a few dates but I'm not
really into her I would never sleep with
her because I know that that that it's a
wrong word but that's an extreme example
though what about like say a girl's
being with like two or three guys like
it's not the end of the world right
she's still a nice guy I honestly I
don't like sleeping around to begin with
so like I don't like going with random
girls and especially if they really love
me like I don't really like breaking
hearts because another thing is I feel
like that's going to come back and bite
me in the ass one day like I really do
believe in energy exchanges and what you
put out there comes back around
um
so I don't want to be breaking hearts
and I'm not worried about getting my
heart broken down the line but causing
that suffering I'm just not a fan of
that yeah but that's why I think like
this whole but especially with more
innocent women because the more
promiscuous they are then the less they
don't really get heartbroken anymore and
then that's why yeah but you're talking
about like the kind of women you're
talking about though when you say that
are like women who have got a horrendous
history women who have been with like so
many men but I'm talking like 50 to 100
men like that's that's the kind of woman
that I that I think are talking about
where it's like oh I don't care if we
break a heart like her heart probably
can't even be broken anymore she can't
do the pair bonding and all that
annoying terms that people use
um but but I do think that like just an
ordinary person like I don't know like
men go on about oh I don't want a woman
with baggage who's had a heartbroken but
you did that to like a line of women
yeah so if you want a better Society
like create one make a better Society
well I agree I'm not saying to go around
breaking hearts so I'm on the same thing
right because even if that woman has you
know 20 30 50 bodies right
first one is is contributing to more
damage to that woman and it's
contributing to that problem and if
everybody pulled back and said I'm going
to treat them all with respect
regardless of their past we would
ultimately create push the envelope
towards women acting more worthy of
respect I think so is that kind of what
you're getting do you think it comes
from explaining do you think it comes
from the men not one like the men having
to control their urges and not sleep
around compared to women not alone I
think everybody's got a part to play
responsible the fathers that's who's
responsible well that's it's funny
because at the end of the day it all
does lead back to the family because a
lot of these people you see with with
horrible attributes they're not good
friends they're very promiscuous they're
just messed up in the head you're like
oh yeah where's your family oh my
parents uh they broke up when I was
really part of it it's no one it's no
one party's fault it's multifaceted and
we all have to play our part in changing
Society but it is amazing how many
correlations there are to people being
messed up and not having a strong family
it's like that's the main thing 100 yeah
it's so true um so um Elena a question
for you what are three things that you
would tell Sunny about that's important
in becoming a man like what are three
things that he that you would tell Sunny
is important in being a man the first
thing that I tell Sunny all the time is
some wisdom that was passed on to my
thought from my father to me and my
sisters you know what I'm gonna say
Obviously and it's
you know what you know kid
you don't know [__]
he used to say that and it was annoying
as a kid to hear that but the reality is
as long as you realize that you have a
lot to learn in this life no matter how
much you know that there's more to learn
and you don't necessarily know what it's
like to walk in someone else's shoes you
don't know anything about what you're
going to be walking into next and you
remember to keep an open mind and keep
learning then you're gonna be okay and I
think that's a really important thing
for a man or a woman to not get cocky
and feel like they know everything and
so that's one thing accountability
another thing is
um integrity and keeping your word if
you can keep your word you're going to
be more valuable than 99.9 of the human
beings
does what he says he's going to do to me
that's like right yeah that's hot even
in a friendship like you know like not
you know that kind of Attraction but
like with a woman or that I'm friends
with like somebody that keeps their word
it is just like
damn that's a quality person that I want
to spend more time with and I get very
frustrated with people who have no
discipline
you know and I have undisciplined areas
too like not like I'm some you know Navy
SEAL but I I really respect that
um let's see third
I guess just I uh you know this is a
tough on the spot kind of question so
I'm gonna wing this one but be careful
who you surround yourself with you will
become the average of The Five People
You spend the most time with so find
people who have values that you aspire
to
had a daughter what three
no I just have this one okay so yeah if
you had a daughter what three things
would you say she should do to become a
good woman
from
I think as I get older I become more and
more conservative yeah
you know and I would tell her to respect
her body and be very much more demure
that she can be
sexy and classy
at the same time you know I would teach
her to keep her mind Sharp
you know be very well aware of what's
going on in the world read read read
read
Because if you're gonna you know be a
valuable mother wife
employee member of society you you gotta
know you've got to be able to hold your
own in a conversation and know what's
going on
the third thing is probably you know
what you know
you don't know [__] yeah okay so it's
sunny what is your goal at the moment
then
can you want to continue to create
content with your mom do you want to go
do more like crypto stuff like what's
your goal right now no not as much
crypto stuff so me and my mom she's
actually launching her own channel she's
been doing it for a couple months now
it's called the beast mother so make
sure you guys go subscribe but we're
going to continue making mom reacts
videos there since those are relatively
easy to do you sit down in front of the
camera watch something and upload it and
then I've set up my system so that's all
automated and then on my main Channel I
really just want to make as as good as
videos as possible so I really like
doing a lot of the street interview
stuff did you watch any of my more
artistic videos lately I haven't seen
autistic videos but I've seen all your
streams but um yeah I got a lot of
inspiration for those from working with
snico because I got to see the behind
the scenes of him making his and that
was definitely a really cool experience
and it rubbed off on me and the crazy
thing is like I would have never seen
myself being able to like direct a video
and do something like that yeah but
anyone can do any of this stuff anyone
can turn the camera on and do this
um and then I also want to switch into
more entrepreneurial type videos so sort
of like Iman godzi and those guys do so
not as much crypto but teaching people
what what I've learned so far about
marketing business and just any way that
I can provide value because all I really
want to do is help out other people and
change lives you know I'm not here to
promote crypto scams and casino gambling
I've already gotten pretty big offers
and I would never do that yeah that's
interesting so where can people follow
you guys I know the based mother on
YouTube yes yes Sonny how can people
follow you and get in touch with you
it's sunny fast on all socials and uh
the sunny fast on Twitter
I want to thank you guys so much for
coming on it's been so fascinating
hearing your story hearing the dynamic
and uh yeah we'll have to do another
catch up soon awesome thank you Leah
thanks so much for coming on thank you
so much this is really fun of course
thanks so much for watching if you
enjoyed this episode please don't forget
to hit the like button and subscribe as
I'll be bringing you a lot more of this
content